the following is a conversation with
Richard Dawkins an evolutionary
biologist and author of The Selfish Gene
the blind watchmaker The God Delusion
the magic of reality and the greatest
show of Earth and his latest Isle
growing God he is the originator and
popularizer of a lot of fascinating
ideas in evolutionary biology and
science in general including funny
enough the introduction of the word meme
in his 1976 book The Selfish Gene which
in the context of a gene-centred view of
evolution is an exceptionally powerful
idea
he's outspoken bold and often fearless
in the defense of science and reason and
in this way is one of the most
influential thinkers of our time this
conversation was recorded before the
outbreak of the pandemic for everyone
feeling the medical psychological and
financial burden of this crisis I'm
sending wealth your way stay strong
we're in this together we'll beat this
thing this is the artificial
intelligence podcast if you enjoy it
subscribe on YouTube review it with five
stars on a podcast supported on patreon
or simply connect with me on Twitter and
lex Friedman spelled Fri D ma n as usual
I'll do a few minutes of ads now and
never any ads in the middle that can
break the flow of the conversation I
hope that works for you and doesn't hurt
the listening experience
this show is presented by cash app the
number one finance app in the App Store
when you get it you just collects
podcast cash app lets you send money to
friends buy Bitcoin and invest in the
stock market with as little as one
dollar since cash app allows you to send
and receive money digitally peer-to-peer
security in all digital transactions is
very important let me mention the PCI
data security standard a cash app is
compliant with I'm a big fan of
standards for safety and security PCI
DSS is a good example of that or a bunch
of competitors got together and agreed
that there needs to be a global standard
around the security of transactions now
we just need to do the same for
autonomous vehicles and artificial
intelligence systems in general so again
if you get cash app from the App Store
Google Play and use the collects podcast
you get ten dollars in cash up will also
donate ten dollars the first an
organization that is helping to advance
robotics and STEM education for young
people around the world and now here's
my conversation with Richard Dawkins
do you think there's intelligent life
out there in the universe well if we
accept that intelligent life here and
reassess the number of planets in the
universe is gigantic I mean 10 to 22
stars has been estimated it seems to me
highly likely that there is not only
life in the universe elsewhere but also
intelligent life if you deny that then
you're committed to the view that the
things that happened on this planet are
staggeringly improbable I mean
ludicrously off-the-charts improbable
and I don't think it's that improbable
certainly the origin of life itself
they're really two steps the origin of
life which is probably fairly improbable
and then the subsequent evolution to
intelligent life which is also fairly a
problem so the juxtaposition of those
two you could say is pretty improbable
but not 10 to the 22 in problem it's an
interesting question maybe you're coming
on to it how we would recognize
intelligence from outer space if we if
we encountered it the most likely way we
would come across them would be by radio
it's highly unlikely they'd ever visit
us but um it's not it's not that
unlikely that we would pick up radio
signals and then we would have to have
some means of deciding as it was
intelligent people have people involved
in the SETI program discuss how they
would do it and things like prime
numbers would be an obvious thing to and
always an obvious way for them to
broadcast to say we are intelligent we
are here I suspect it probably would be
obvious actually that's interesting
prime number so the mathematical
patterns it's an open question whether
mathematics is the same for us and as it
would be for aliens I suppose we could
assume that ultimately if we were
governed by the same laws of physics and
we should be governed by the same laws
of mathematics I think so
I suspect that they will have Pythagoras
theorem etc and I don't think that
mathematics will be that different do
you think evolution would also be a
force on the alien planets I stuck my
neck out and said that if we do if ever
that we do discover life elsewhere it
will be Darwinian life in the sense that
it will but it will work by some kind of
natural selection the non-random
survival of non of Rann
the regenerated codes it doesn't mean it
that the genera have to have some kind
of genetics but it doesn't have to be
DNA genetics probably wouldn't be
actually but it would I think it would
have to be Darwinian yes there's some
kind of selection process yes in the
general sense it will be Darwinian so
let me ask kind of artificial
intelligence engineering questions so
you've been an outspoken critic of I
guess what could be called intelligent
design which is an attempt to describe
the creation of a human mind a body by
some religious folks that really just
folks used to describe so broadly
speaking evolution is as far as I know
again you can correct me is the only
scientific theory we have for the
development of intelligent life like
there's no alternative theory as far as
as far as I understand none has ever
been suggested and I suspect it never
will be
well of course one of the somebody says
that a hundred years later I know but um
that I mean not what he would look sorry
yes they would probably look very
similar but it'd be it's almost like
Einstein's general relativity versus
Newtonian physics it'll be maybe an
alteration of the theory or something
like that but it won't be fundamentally
different but okay it so so now for the
past 70 years even before the a a
committee has been trying to engineer
intelligence in a sense to do what
intelligent design says the you know was
done here on earth what's your intuition
do you think it's possible to build
intelligence to build computers that are
intelligent or do we need to do
something like the evolutionary process
like there's there's no shortcuts here
that's an interesting question
i I'm committed to the belief that is
ultimately possible because I think
there's nothing normal in our brains I
think how our brains work by by the laws
of physics and so it must in principle
it be possible to replicate that in
practice though it might be very
difficult and as you suggest it might it
may be the only way to do it is by
something like an evolutionary process
I'd be surprised I suspect that it will
come but it's certainly been slower
incoming than some of the early pioneers
I thought I thought it would be yeah but
in your sense is the evolutionary
process efficient so you can see it as
exceptionally wasteful in one
perspective but at the same time maybe
that is the only path it's a paradox
isn't it I mean on the one side it is
deplorable it wasteful yeah it's
fundamentally based on waste on the
other hand it does produce magnificent
results when the the the design of a
soaring bird an albatross has David and
a vulture an eagle is superb an engineer
would be proud to have done it on the
other hand an engineer would not be
proud to have done some of the other
things that evolution has served up some
of the sort of botched jobs that you can
easily understand because of their
historical origins but they don't look
well designed your examples well bad
design my favorite example is there a
current laryngeal nerve I've used this
many times this is a nerve it's one of
the cranial nerves it goes from the
brain and the end organ is that it
supplies is the Voicebox
theme the larynx but it doesn't go
straight to the layers it goes right in
done to the chest and then loops around
an artery in the chest and then come
straight back up again to the larynx and
I've assisted in the dissection of a
giraffe's neck which happened to have
died in a zoo and we watched the we saw
the recurrent laryngeal nerve going
whizzing straight past the larynx within
an inch of the larynx down into the
chest and then back up again which is a
detour of many feet very very
inefficient the reason is historical the
ancestors are fish ancestors the
ancestors of all mammals and fish the
most direct pathway of that of the
equivalent of that nerve there wasn't
the larynx in those days but it did
innovated part of the gills the most
direct pathway was behind that artery
and then when the mammal when the
tetrapods were in the land vertebra
started ever evolving and then the next
started to stretch the marginal cost
of changing the embryo logical design to
jump that nerve over the artery was too
great a rather was was each step of the
way was of was a very small cost but the
marginal but the cost of actually
jumping it over would have been very
large as the neck lengthened it was a
negligible change to just increase the
length the length of the detour tiny bit
a tiny bit a tiny bit each millimeter
time didn't make any difference
and so but finally when you get towards
araf it's a huge detour and no doubt is
very inefficient now that's bad design
any engineer would reject that piece of
jade design is ridiculous and there are
quite a number of examples as you'd
expect it's not surprising that we find
examples of that sort in a way what's
surprising is there aren't more of them
in a way what's surprising is that the
design of living things is so good so
natural selection manages to achieve
excellent results partly by tinkering
partly by coming along and cleaning up
initial mistakes and in as it were
making the best of a bad job that's an
interesting I mean it's it is surprising
and beautiful and it's a it's a mystery
from an engineering perspective that so
many things are well designed I suppose
the thing we're forgetting is how many
generations have to die oh yeah for
that's the inefficiency of it yes that's
the horrible wastefulness of it so yeah
we we marvel at the final product but
yeah the process is painful
he almost describes human beings as
potentially the well he calls the
biological bootloader for artificial
intelligence or artificial general
intelligence is used as the term is kind
of like super intelligence do you see
super human level intelligence that's
potentially the next step in the
evolutionary process yes I think that if
superhuman intelligence is to be found
it will be artificial I don't have any
hope that we ourselves our brains will
go on in go on getting larger in
ordinary biological evolution I think
that's probably coming to an end it is
the dominant trend or one of the
dominant trends in our fossil history
for the last two or three million years
raised eyes yes
so it's been it's been swelling rather
dramatically over the last two or three
million years that is unlikely to
continue that the only way that that's
that happens is because natural
selection favors those individuals with
the biggest brains and that's not
happening anymore right there so in
general in humans the the selection
pressures are not I mean are they active
in any form well in order for them to be
active it would be necessary that the
most intelligent intelligence not that
intelligence is simply correlation with
brain size but let's let's talk about
intelligence in order for that to evolve
it's necessary that the most intelligent
beings have the most individuals have
the most children and so intelligence
may buy you money it may buy you worldly
success it may buy you a nice house and
a nice car and things like that if you
successful career it may buy you the
admiration of your fellow people but it
doesn't increase the number of offspring
that you have it doesn't increase your
genetic legacy to the next generation
well on the other hand artificial
intelligence I mean computers and
technology generally is evolving by a
non genetic means by leaps and bounds of
course and so what do you think I don't
know if you're familiar there's a
company called neural link but there's a
general effort of brain computer
interfaces which is to try to build a
connection between the computer and the
brains with their scent signals both
directions and the long-term dream there
is to do exactly that which is expand
I guess expand the size of the brain
expand the capabilities of the brain do
you do you see this is interesting and
do you see this is the promising
possible technology or is the interface
you see in the computer in the brain
like the brain is this wet messy thing
that's just impossible to interface with
well of course it's interesting whether
it's promising I'm really not qualified
to say what I do find puzzling is that
the brain being as small as it is
compared to a computer Andy
the individual components being as slow
as they are compared to our electronic
components it is astonishing or it can
do I mean
imagine building a computer that that
fits into the size of a human skull and
with the equivalent of transistors or
integrated circuits which work as slowly
as neurons do it something mysterious
about that something something must be
going on that we don't understand so I
have I just talked to Roger Penrose I'm
not sure he's familiar with this work
and he also describes this kind of
mystery in in the mind in the brain that
is receives a materialist so there's not
there's no sort of mystical thing going
on but there's so much about the
material of the brain that we don't
understand at the that might be quantum
mechanical nature so on so they're the
ideas about consciousness do you have
any have you ever thought about do you
ever think about ideas of consciousness
or a little bit more about the mystery
of intelligence and consciousness that
seems to pop up just like you're saying
from our brain I agree with Roger
Penrose that there's a mystery there I I
even he's one of the world's greatest
physicists III can't possibly argue with
his but nobody knows anything about
consciousness and in fact you know if we
talk about religion and so on some of
the mystery of consciousness is so
awe-inspiring and we know so little
about it that the leap to sort of
religious or mystical explanations is
too easy to make i I think that it's
just an act of cowardice to lead to
religious explanations and what it
doesn't do that of course but I I accept
that there may be something we don't
understand about it so correct me if I'm
wrong but in your book Selfish Gene the
the gene-centred view of evolution Allah
allows us to think of the physical
organisms as just the medium through
which the software of our genetics and
the ideas sort of propagate so maybe can
we start
just with a little basics what in this
context as the word meme mean it would
mean the cultural equivalent of a gene
cultural equivalent in the sense of that
which plays the same role as the gene in
the transmission of culture and the
transmission of ideas in the broadest
sense and it's only a useful word if
there's something Darwinian going on
obviously culture is transmitted but is
there anything Darwinian going on and if
there is that means there has to be
something like a gene which it which
becomes more numerous or less numerous
in the population so it can replicate it
can replicate well it clearly does
replicate there's no question about that
the question is does it replicate in a
sort of differential way in a Darwinian
fashion could you say that certain ideas
propagate because they're successful in
the meme pool and it's not a trivial
sense you can would you wish to say
though that in the same way as a animal
body is modified adapted to serve as a
machine for propagating genes is it also
machined for propagating memes could you
actually say that something about the
way a human is is is modified adapted
for the function of beam propagation
there are such a fascinating possibility
if that's true if the that it's not just
about the genes which seems somehow more
come from comprehensible so that these
things of biology the the the the idea
that culture or maybe ideas you can
really broadly define it yes operations
of these mechanism II it does does
evolve by pneumatic means I mean things
like hairstyles styles of makeup
circumcision these things are actual
changes in the body form yes
which are non genetic and which get
passed on from generation to generation
or sideways like a virus um in in a
quasi genetic way but the moment you
start drifting away from the physical a
big
interesting is a space of ideas
ideologies political system of course
yes so what's what in your what's your
sense is our memes are metaphor more or
they really is there something
fundamental almost physical presence of
memes well I think they're a bit more
than a metaphor and and I think that um
and I mentioned that physical bodily
characteristics which are a bit trivial
in a way but when things like the
propagation of religious ideas both
longitudinally down generations and
transversely as in a sort of
Epidemiology of ideas when of
charismatic preacher converts people
that that's that resembles viral
transmission whereas the the
longitudinal transmission from
grandparent to parent a child etc is is
more like conventional genetic
transmission this is such a beautiful
expression especially in the modern day
idea do you think about this implication
social networks where the propagation of
ideas the viral propagation of ideas
enhancing the new use of the word meme
the describe the the the Internet of
course provides extremely rapid method
of travel ambition and before when I
first coined the word the internet
didn't exist and so I was thinking that
in terms of books newspapers broader
radio television and that kind of thing
now an idea can just leap around the
world in in all directions instantly and
so the Internet provides a step change
in the facility of propagation of memes
how does that make you feel isn't it
fascinating that sort of ideas it's like
you haven't go up against islands or
something is the 70s and the internet
allowed all these species is just like
global eyes and and in a matter of
seconds you could spread a message to
millions of people and these ideas these
memes can breed
can evolve can mutate and there's a
selection and there's like different I
guess groups that of all like there's a
dynamics it's fascinating here do you
think yes basically do you think your
work in this direction while
fundamentally was focused on life on
Earth do you think it should continue
like to be well yeah I do think it would
probably be a good idea to think in a
Darwinian way about this sort of thing
we could mention you think of the
transmission of ideas from in
evolutionary context just being limited
to I mean in our ancestors people living
in villages living in small bands where
everybody knew each other and ideas
could propagate within the village and
they might hop to a neighboring village
occasionally and maybe able to a
neighboring continent eventually and
that was a slow process nowadays
villages are international I mean you
have people it's been called echo
chambers where people are in a sort of
Internet village where the other members
of the village may be geographically
distributed all over the world whether
they just happen to be interested in the
same things use the same terminology
the same jargon have the same enthusiasm
so people like the Flat Earth Society
they don't all live in one place they
find each other and they talk the same
language to each other they talk the
same nonsense to each other
and they but so this is a kind of
distributed version of the primitive
idea of of people living in in villages
and propagating their ideas in in a
local way is there is there a Darwinist
parallel parallel here so is their
evolutionary purpose of villages or is
that just the I wouldn't use the word
like evolutionary purpose in that play
at that case but vient villages or
religious will be something that just
emerged that's the way people happen to
live and in it just the same kind of way
the Flat Earth Society societies of
ideas emerge in the same kind of way in
this digital space yes yes is there
something interesting to say about the
I guess from a perspective of Darwin
could we fully interpret the dynamics of
social interaction and these social
networks or is there or some much more
complicated thing need to be developed
like what's your sense well a Darwinian
selection idea would involve
investigating which ideas spread in
which which don't so in some ideas don't
have the ability to spread in the flat
earth flatter earth ism is is there are
a few people believe in it but it's not
going to spread because it's obvious
nonsense but other ideas even if they
are wrong can spread because they are
attractive in some sense so the the
spreading in the selection and in the
Darwinian context is it just has to be
attractive in some sense like we don't
have to define like it doesn't have to
be attractive in the way that animals
attract each other
it could be attractive and some other
one yes it's it's all that matters is
all it's needed easily to spread and it
doesn't have to be true to spread
increases one criterion which might help
an idea to spread but there are other
criteria which might help it to spread
as you say attraction in animals is not
necessarily available for survival the
celebrated of the famous Peacocks tail
doesn't help the peacock to survive it
helps it to pass on its genes similarly
an idea which is actually rubbish but
which people don't know is robbed we
shouldn't think is very attractive will
spread in the same way as a peacocks
gene spread it's a small sidestep I
remember reading somewhere I think
recently that in some species of birds
sort of the idea that beauty may have
its own purpose and the idea that some
some birds I'm being in eloquent here
but there is some aspects of their
feathers and so on that serve no
evolutionary purpose whatsoever there's
somebody making an argument that there
are some things about beauty that
animals do that may be its own purpose
that
does that ring a bell for you it sound
ridiculous he's rather distorted Bell
okay Darwin when he coined the phrase
sexual selection yes didn't feel the
need to suggest that what was attractive
to females usually as males attracting
females the what females found
attractive had to be useful he said it
didn't have to be useful it was enough
that females found it attractive and so
it could be completely useless probably
was completely useless in the
conventional sense but was not at all
useless in the sense of passing on don't
augment in column genes but essentially
reproducing others starting with Wallace
the co-discoverer of natural selection
didn't like that idea and they wanted
sexually selected characteristics like
peacock tails to be in some sense useful
it's a bit of a stretch to think of a
peacock say was being useful but in the
in the in the sense of survival but
others have run with that idea and have
brought it up to date and so there's a
kind of there are two schools of thought
on sexual selection which are still
active and about equally supported now
those who follow Darwin in thinking that
is just enough to say it's attractive
and those who follow Wallace and say
that it has to be in some sense useful
do you fall into one category or the
other no I mean you're into minded I
think they both could be correct in
different cases well I mean they've both
been made sophisticated in a
mathematical sense more so than when
Darwin and Wallace first started talking
about it
I'm Russian I read a romanticized thing
so I prefer the former yes with it or
the beauty in itself as a powerful so
the attraction is a powerful force in
evolution on religion do you think there
will ever be a time in our future where
almost nobody believes in God or God is
not a part of the moral fabric of our
society yes I do I think it may happen
I'll for very long time it may take a
long time for that to happen so do you
think ultimately for everybody
on earth religion the other forms of
doctrines ideas could do better job than
what religion does yes
I mean following in truth at least what
truth is a funny funny word and reason
to theirs yeah it's a it's a difficult
idea
now with truth on the Internet right and
fake news and so on I suppose when you
say reason you mean the very basic sort
of inarguable conclusions of science
versus which political system is better
yeah yes yes I mean truth about the real
world which is ascertainable by not just
by the more rigorous methods of science
but by just ordinary sensory observation
so do you think there will ever be a
time when we move past it like I guess
another way to ask it are we hopelessly
fundamentally tied to religion in the
way our society functions well clearly
all individuals are not hopelessly tied
to it because many individuals don't
believe you could mean something like
society needs religion in order to
function properly or something like that
and some people have suggested that some
what's your intuition on there well I've
read books on it and they're persuasive
I don't think they're that persuasive
though I mean I've some people suggested
that society needs a sort of figurehead
which can be a non-existent figurehead
in order to function properly I know
there's something rather patronizing
about the idea that well you and I are
intelligent enough not to believe in God
but the plebs needed sort of thing and I
think that's patronizing and I'd like to
think that that that was not the right
way to proceed but at the individual
level do you think there's some value of
spirituality sort of if I think
as a scientist the amount of things we
actually know about our universe is a
tiny tiny tiny percentage of what we
could possibly know so just from
everything even the certainty we have
about the laws of physics it seems to be
that there's yet a huge amount to
discover and therefore we're sitting
where 99.999% of things is just still
shrouded in mystery do you think there's
a role in a kind of spiritual view of
that sort of a humbled spiritual I think
it's right to be humble
I think it's right to admit that there's
a lot we don't know a lot that we don't
understand a lot but we still need to
work on we're working on it what I don't
think is that it helps to invoke
supernatural explanations what we found
if our current scientific explanations
aren't adequate to do the job then we
need better ones we need to work more
and of course the history of science
shows just that that as science goes on
problems get solved one after another
and the science advances as science gets
better but to invoke an non-scientific
non-physical explanation is simply to
lie down in a cowardly way and say we
can't solve it so again to invoke magic
don't let's do that let's say we need
better science we need more science it
may be that the science will never do it
it may be that we will never actually
understand everything and that's okay
but let's keep working on it a
challenging question there is do you
think science can lead us astray in
terms of the humbleness so there's some
aspect of science
maybe it's the aspect of scientists in
that science but of sort of a mix of ego
and confidence that can lead us astray
in terms of discovering them you know
some of the big open questions about yes
about the universe I think that's right
I mean there are there are arrogant
people in any walk of life and
scientists an exception to that and so
there are arrogant scientists who think
we've sold everything of course we
haven't so humility is a proper stance
for a scientist and when it's a proper
working stance because it encourages
further work but in a way to resort to a
supernatural explanation is a kind of
arrogance because it's saying well we
don't understand it scientifically
therefore the non-scientific religious
supernatural explanation must be the
right one that's arrogant what is what
is humble is to say we don't know and we
need to work further on it
so maybe if I could psychoanalyze you
for a second you have at times been just
slightly frustrated with people who have
supernet you know have a supernatural
has that changed over the years have you
become like how do people that kind of
have to seek supernatural explanations
how do you see those people as human
beings as it's like do you see them as
dishonest do you see them as sort of
ignorant do you see them as I don't know
is it like well I mean how do you think
of certainly not not not dishonest and I
mean obviously many of them are very
nice people so I don't I don't sort of
despise them in that sense I think it's
often a misunderstanding that that
people will jump from the admission that
we don't understand something they will
jump straight to what they think of as
an alternative explanation which is the
supernatural one which is not an
alternative it's a known explanation
instead of jumping to the conclusion
that science needs more work that we
need to actually get do some better
better science so I I don't have I mean
personal antipathy towards such people I
just think they're they're misguided so
what about this really interesting space
that I have trouble with so religion
ever but a grasp on but there's a large
communities like you said flat earth a
community that I've recently because
I've made a few jokes about it I saw
that there's I've noticed that there's
people that to take it quite seriously
so there's this bigger world of
conspiracy theorists
which is the kind of I mean there's
elements of it there are religious as
well but I think they're also scientific
so the the basic credo of a conspiracy
theorist is to question everything which
is also the cradle of a good scientist I
would say so what do you make of this I
mean I think it's probably too easy to
say that by labeling something
conspiracy you therefore dismiss it I
mean occasionally conspiracies are right
and so we shouldn't dismiss conspiracy
theories out of hand we should examine
them on their own merits Flat Earth is
amiss obvious nonsense we don't have to
examine that much further but I mean
there may be other conspiracy theories
which are actually right so I've go a
grew up in the Soviet Union as I you
know the space race was very influential
for me and both sides of the coin you
know there's a conspiracy theory that we
never went to the moon right and it's
it's like I can understand it and it's
very difficult to rigorously
scientifically show one way or the other
it's just you have to use some of the
human intuition about who would have to
lie who would have to work together and
it's clear that very unlikely good
behind that is my general intuition that
most people in this world are good you
know in order to really put together
some conspiracy theories there has to be
a large number of people working
together and essentially being dishonest
yes which is improbable it the sheer
number who would have to be in on this
conspiracy and the sheer detail the
attention to detail they'd have had to
have had and so on I'd also can worry
about the motive and why would anyone
want to suggest that it but it didn't
happen what's the what's the why is it
so hard to believe I mean the the
physics of it the mathematics of it the
the idea of computing orbits and
trajectories and things it all works
mathematically well I like wouldn't you
believe it
it's a psychology question because
there's something really Pleasant about
you know pointing out that the emperor
has no clothes when everybody like you
know thinking outside the box and coming
up with the chewy answer where everybody
else is deluded there's something yeah I
mean I have that for science right you
want to prove the entire scientific
community wrong that's the whole now
that that's that's right and of course
historically loan geniuses have come out
right sometimes yes but often people
with who think they're alone genius and
from much more often turn out not to so
you have to judge each case on its
merits then the mere fact that you're a
maverick the mere fact that you you
you're going against the current tide
doesn't make you right you've got a FRU
show you're right by looking at the
evidence
so because you focus so much on religion
and disassembled a lot of ideas there
and I just I was wondering if you have
ideas about conspiracy theory groups
because there's such a prevalent even
reaching into presidential politics and
so on it seems like it's a very large
communities that believe different kinds
of conspiracy theories is there some
connection there to your thinking on
religion and here is it's a matter it's
an obviously difficult thing IIIi don't
understand why people believe things
that are clearly nonsense like well Flat
Earth and also the conspiracy about not
landing on the moon or that the that the
United States engineer 9/11 that that
kind of thing so it's not clearly
nonsense it's extremely unlikely though
a it's extremely unlikely the religion
is a bit different because it's passed
down from generation to generation and
so many of the people who are religious
got it from their parents who got it
from their parents got it from their
parents and childhood indoctrination is
a very powerful force but these things
like the 9/11 conspiracy theory the
Kennedy assassination conspiracy theory
the man on the moon conspiracy theory
these are not childhood indoctrination
these are presumably dreamed up by
somebody who then tells somebody else
who then wants to believe it and I don't
know why people
so eager to fall in line with some just
some person that they happen to read or
meet who spin some yarn I can kind of
understand why they believe what their
parents and teachers told them when they
were very tiny and not capable of
critical thinking for themselves so I
sort of get why the great religions of
the world like Catholicism and Islam go
on for as persisting is because of
childhood indoctrination but that's not
true of Flat Earth ISM and sure enough
flat earth ISM is a very minority cult
way larger than I ever realized well yes
I know but so that's a really clean idea
you've articulate in your new book and
and and I'll groan God and then God
Delusion
is the early indoctrination that's
really interesting you can get away with
a lot of out there ideas in terms of
religious texts if the age which you
convey those ideas at first is a young
age so indoctrination is sort of an
essential element of propagation of
religion so let me ask on the morality
side in the books that I mentioned God
Delusion I'll go on God you describe the
human beings don't need religion to be
moral so from an engineering perspective
we want to engineer morality into AI
systems so in general where do you think
morals come from in humans a very
complicated and interesting question
it's clear to me that the moral
standards the moral values of our
civilization changes as the decades go
by certainly as the centuries go by even
as the decades go by and we in the 21st
century are quite clearly labeled 21st
century people in terms of our moral
values we there's a spread I mean some
of us are a little bit more ruthless
somewhat more conservative some of us
more more liberal and so on but we all
subscribe to pretty much the same views
when you compare
with say 18th century 17th century
people even 19th century 20th century
people so we're much less racist or a
much less sexist and so on than we used
to be some some people are still racist
in some are still sexist but the the
spread has shifted that the Gaussian
distribution has moved and moves
steadily as the centuries go by and that
is the most powerful influence I can see
on our moral values and that doesn't
have anything to do with religion I mean
the religion of the these are the morals
of the Old Testament Bronze Age models
morals they're deplorable
and they are to be understood in terms
of the people in in the desert who made
them up at the time and so human
sacrifice an eye for an eye a tooth for
a tooth petty revenge killing people for
breaking the Sabbath all that kind of
thing
inconceivable No so at some point
religious texts may have in part
reflected that Gaussian distribution at
that time I did I'm sure they always
reflect that yes and then now but the
the sort of almost like the meme as you
describe it of ideas most much faster
than religious annual is yes so basing
your morals on on religious texts which
were written millennia ago um it is not
a great way to proceed I think that's
pretty clear so not only should we not
get our morals from such text but we
don't we quite clearly don't um if we
did then we would be discriminating
against women and we'd be we'd be racist
we'd be killing homosexuals and so on so
so we don't and we shouldn't now of
course it's possible to buy the to use
the 21st century standards of morality
and you can look at the Bible and you
can cherry-pick particular verses which
conform to our modern morality and
you'll find that Jesus has a pretty nice
thing
which is great but you're using your
21st century morality to decide which
verses to pick which verses to reject
and so why not cut out the middleman of
the Bible and go straight to the 21st
century morality which is where that
comes from is a much more complicated
question why is it that morality moral
values change as the centuries go by
they undoubtedly do and is a very
interesting question to ask why it's
another example of cultural evolution
just as technology progresses so moral
values progress for probably very
different reasons but it's a it's
interesting if the direction in which
that progress is happening has some
evolutionary value or if it's merely a
drift that can go into any direction no
choice any direction and I'm not sure
evolutionarily valuable what it is is
progressive in the sense that each step
is a step in the same direction as the
previous step so it becomes more gentle
more decent as by modern standards more
liberal less violent see but more decent
I think you're using terms and
interpreting everything in the context
of the 21st century
yeah because Genghis Khan will probably
say that this is not more decent because
we're now you know there's a lot of weak
members of society we're not murdering
yes I was careful to say bye-bye the
stands the 21st century by up by our
standards if we with hindsight look back
at history what we see is a trend in the
direction towards us towards our present
right a present value for us we see
progress but it's it's an open question
whether that won't you know I don't see
necessarily why we can never return to
Genghis Khan test we could I suspect we
weren't but it but if you look at the
history of moral values over the
centuries it is in a progressive I use
the word progressive not in a value
judgment sense in the sense of of a
transitive sense each step is the same
in the same direction of the previous
step so things like we don't derive
entertainment for
torturing cats we don't drive
entertainment from from like the Romans
did in the Coliseum from from that state
rather or rather we suppress the desire
to get I mean to have play it's probably
in us somewhere so there's a bunch of
parts of our brain one that probably you
know limbic system that wants certain
pleasures and that's this I didn't I
mean I I wouldn't have said that but
your Liberty to think that like well
there's a there's a den Carlin of
hardcore history there's a really nice
explanation of how we've enjoyed
watching the torture of people the
fighting of people just the torture the
suffering of people throughout history
as entertainment until quite recently
and now everything we do with sports or
kind of channeling that feeling into
something else so I mean there's some
dark aspects of human nature there are
underneath everything and I do hope this
like higher level software we've built
will keep us at bay yes I'm also Jewish
and have history with the Soviet Union
in the Holocaust and I clearly remember
that some of the darker aspects of human
nature creeped out there they do that
there have been they have been steps
back was 200 admittedly and and the
Holocaust is obvious one but if you take
a broad view of history it's it's in the
same direction so Pamela McCord ik in
machines who think has written that AI
began with the ancient wish to forge the
gods do you see it's it's a poetic
description I suppose but DC connection
between our civilizations historic
desire to create gods to create
religions and our modern desire to
create technology in intelligent
technology I suppose there's a link
between an ancient desire explain away
mystery and and science but what
elegance artificial intelligence
creating gods creating new gods and I
forget I read somewhere somewhat
facetious some
paper which said that we have a new
goddess called Google and and we pray to
it and we worship it and we ask its
advice like an Oracle and so on that's
fun
and we you don't see that you see that
as a fun statement of a seizure
statement you don't see that as a kind
of truth of us creating things that are
more powerful than ourselves and
naturally it has a kind of poetic
resonance to it which I get but I
wouldn't but now I wouldn't have
bothered to make the point myself put it
that way
all right so you don't think AI will
become our new got a new religion and
you gods a Google well yes I mean like I
can see that the future of intelligent
machines or indeed intelligent aliens
from outer space might yield beings that
we would regard as gods in the sense
that they are so superior to ask that we
might as well worship them that's highly
possible I think but I see a very
fundamental distinction between a God
who is simply defined as something very
very powerful and intelligent on the one
hand and a God who doesn't need
explaining by a progressive step-by-step
process let's like evolution or like or
like engineering design so the
difference of suppose we did meet an
alien from outer space who was mm-hmm
marvelously magnificently more
intelligent than us and we would sort of
worship it and for that reason
nevertheless it would not be a god in
the very important sense that it did not
just happen by to be to be there like
God is supposed to it must have come
about by a gradual step-by-step
incremental progressive process
presumably like Darwinian evolution is
that there's all the difference in the
world between those two intelligence
design comes into the universe late as a
product of a progressive evolutionary
process or a progressive engineering
design process so most of the work is
done through this slow-moving exactly
exactly yeah yeah it's but there's still
this desire to get answers to the why
question that if we're if the world is a
simulation if we're living in a
simulation that there's a programmer
like creature that we can ask questions
over then let's put let's pursue the
idea that we're living in a simulation
which is not not totally ridiculous by
the way um there we go then you still
need to explain the programmer the
programmer had to come into existence by
some the even if we're innocent in a
simulation the the programmer must have
evolved or if if he's in a sort of more
she or she she she had a meta simulation
then the the meta meta programmer must
have evolved by a gradual process you
can't escape that fundamentally you've
got to come back to a gradual
incremental process of explanation to
start with there's no shortcuts in this
world
but maybe to linger on that point about
the simulation do you think it's an
interesting basically talked to board
the the heck out of everybody asking
this question but whether you live in a
simulation do you think first do you
think we live in a simulation second do
you think it's an interesting thought
experiment it's certainly an interesting
thought experiment i first met it in a
science fiction novel by daniel gal I
called counterfeit world in which it's
all about I mean III our heroes are
running a gigantic computer which which
simulates the world and and something
goes wrong and so one of them has to go
down into the simulated world in order
to fix it and then the the the Dynamo of
the thing the climate so novel is that
they discover themselves in another
simulation at a high level so I was
intrigued by this and I love others of
Daniel gallows science-fiction novels
then it was revived seriously by Nick
Bostrom boss from talking to
in an hour okay and he goes further not
just treated as a science fiction
speculation he actually thinks it's
positively likely yeah I mean it's very
likely actually well he's he makes like
a probabilistic argument which you can
use to come up with very interesting
conclusions about the nature of this
universe I mean he think he thinks that
that that we are in a simulation done by
it so to speak are descendants of a
future that the products but it's still
a product of evolution it's still
ultimately going to be a product of
evolution even though the super
intelligent people of the future have
created our world and you and I are just
a simulation in this table is a
simulation and so on I don't actually in
my heart of hearts believe it but that I
like his argument well so the
interesting thing is that I agree with
you but the interesting thing to me if I
would say if we're living in a
simulation that in that simulation to
make it work you still have to do
everything gradually just like you said
that even though it's program I don't
think there could be miracles otherwise
we'll know I mean the the programmer the
higher up the upper ones have to have
evolved gradually however the simulation
they create could be instantaneous I
mean it could be switched on and we come
into the world with fabricated memories
true but what I'm what I'm trying to
convey so you're saying the the broader
statement but I'm saying from an
engineering perspective both the
programmer has to be slowly evolved and
the simulation because it's like yeah
I'm an engineering perspective yeah it
takes a long time to write a program no
like just I don't think you can create
the universe in a snap I think you have
to grow it ok well that's and that's a
good point
that's an arguable point by the way um I
I have thought about using the Nick
Bostrom
eye idea to solve the riddle of how we
were talking we were talking earlier
about why the human brain can achieve so
much I thought of this when my then
hundred year old mother was marveling at
what I could do with it with us
Bart phone and and I could you know
Koren look up anything in the
encyclopedia I could play her music that
she liked and so on Jen please it's all
left in that tiny little firm no it's
it's out there it's in it's in the cloud
it's and maybe what most of what we do
is in a cloud so maybe if if we're if we
are a simulation yeah then all the power
that we think is in our skull it
actually may be like the power that we
think is in the iPhone but is that
actually out there it's an interface to
something else yeah I mean that's what
beautiful including Roger Penrose with
Penn psychism that consciousness is
somehow a fundamental part of physics
that it doesn't have to actually all
reside inside network but Roger thinks
it does reside in in the skull whereas
I'm suggesting that it doesn't that it's
that there's a cloud that'd be a
fascinating fascinating notion and a
small tangent are you familiar with the
work of Donald Hoffman I guess maybe
nothing is named correctly but just to
forget the name the idea that there's a
difference between reality and
perception so like we biological
organisms perceive the world in order
for the natural selection process to be
able to survive and so on but that
doesn't mean that our perception
actually reflects the fundamental
reality the physical reality or in you
well I do think that although it
reflects the fundamental reality I do
believe there is a fundamental reality I
do think that what the perception is
constructive in the sense that we
construct in our minds a model of what
we're seeing and so and this is really
the view of people who work on visual
illusions like Richard Gregory who point
out other things like an echo cube which
flipped from a two-dimensional picture
of a cube on on on sheet of paper but we
see it as a three-dimensional cube and
it flips from one orientation to another
at regular intervals what's going on is
that the brain is is constructing a cube
but
the sense-data are compatible with two
alternative cubes and so rather than
stick with one of them it alternates
between them I think that's just a a
model for what we do all the time when
we see a table when we see a person when
we see a let me see anything we're using
the sense data to construct or or make
use of a preps previously constructed
model I noticed this when when I meet
somebody who actually is say a friend of
mine but I until I kind of realized that
that is him he looks different and then
when I finally o'clock that it's him
his features switch like a neck and cube
just into the familiar form as it were
I've taken his face out of the filing
cabinet inside and grafted it onto or
used used the sense data to to to you to
in to invoke it yeah we do some kind of
miraculous compression on this whole
thing to be able to filter out most of
the sense data it makes it make sense of
it that's just a magical thing that we
do so you've written several many
amazing books but let me ask what books
technical or fiction of philosophical
had a big impact on your own life what
what books would you recommend people
consider reading in their own
intellectual journey darling of course
and the original I've actually ashamed
to say I've never read Darwin he's
nearly prescient because considering he
was writing in the middle of the 19th
century Michael Uslan said he's working
a hundred years ahead of his time
everything except genetics is that
amazingly right and amazingly far ahead
of his time and of course you need to
read the the up datings that have
happened since his time as well and he
would be astonished by well let alone
Watson and Crick of course but he Brist
honest by Mendelian genetics as well and
fascinated to see what he thought about
the
he would think about oh I mean yes it
would because in many ways it it clears
up what appeared in his time to be a
riddle in the digital nature of genetics
clears up what what was a problem of the
big problem gosh there's so much that I
could think of I can't I can't really
advise there so is there something
outside sort of more fiction is there
when you think young was there books it
just kind of outside of kind of the
realm of science yeah Jim they just kind
of sparked your yes well actually I have
I suppose I could say that I've learned
some some science from science fiction
um I may I meant I mentioned Daniel
gallo but and that's one example which
another of his novels called dark
universe which is not terribly well
known but it's a very very nice science
fiction story it's about a world of
Perpetual darkness and we don't we're
not told a beginning the but why these
people are in darkness they stumble
around in some kind of underground world
of caverns and passages using
echolocation like bats and whales to get
around and they've adapted presumably by
Darwinian means to survive in perpetual
total darkness but what's interesting is
that their mythology their religion has
echoes of Christianity but is based on
light and so there's been a fall from a
from a paradise world that once existed
where light reigned supreme and because
of the sin of mankind light banished
them so then they no longer are in
lights presence but but light survives
in the form of mythology and in the form
of sayings like their great light or
mightier other lights sake don't do that
and I and I I hear what you mean rather
than I see what you don't want you mean
so there's some of the same religious
elements are present in this other
totally kind of absurd different form
yes there's a wonderful I wouldn't call
it set up because it's too good-natured
for that I mean there were a wonderful
power
all about Christianity and the doctrine
the theological doctrine of the fall so
I find that that kind of science fiction
immensely stimulating Fred Hoyles the
black cloud oh by the way anything by
arthur c clarke i find very very
wonderful - fred horns the black cloud
his first science fiction novel where he
well I learned I learned a lot of
science from that it has it suffers from
an obnoxious hero unfortunately but
apart from that he couldn't learn a lot
of science from it another of his novels
the a for Andromeda which by the way the
the theme of that is taken up by Carl
Sagan science fiction novel another
wonderful writer Carl Sagan contact
where the idea is again we will not be
visited from outer space by physical
bodies we will be visited possibly we
might be visited by radio but the the
radio signals could manipulate us and
actually have a concrete influence on
the world if they make us or persuade us
to build a computer which which runs
their software so that they can then
transmit their software by radio and
then the computer takes over the world
and this is the same theme in both
Hoyles book and Sagan spoke I presume
them I don't want to say canoe but halls
book probably did and and but it's a
clever idea that the that we will never
be invaded by physical bodies the War of
the Worlds of HG Wells will never happen
but we could be invaded by radio signals
if code coded information which is sort
of like DNA and and you know we are we
are we are I call them we are survival
machines of our of our DNA so it has
great resonance from for me because I
think of us I think of bodies physical
bodies biological bodies as being
manipulated by
information in DNA which has come down
through generations and in the space of
memes it doesn't have to be physical it
can be transmitted yeah this information
yes that's the fascinating possibility
that from outer space who can be
infiltrated by other memes by other
ideas and thereby controlled in that way
let me ask the last the silliest there
may be the most important question what
is the meaning of life what gives your
life fulfillment perfect a weapon is me
from a scientific point of view the
meaning of life is the propagation of
DNA but that's not what I feel that's
not the meaning of my life so the
meaning of my life is something which is
probably different from yours and
different of other peoples but we we
each make our own meaning so we we have
we set up goals we want to achieve we
want to write a book we want to do
whatever it is we do writer quartet we
want to win a football match and these
are these are short-term girls won't me
begin quite long term goals which are
set up by our brains which have goal
seeking machinery built into them but
what we feel we don't feel motivated by
the desire to pass on our DNA mostly we
have other other girls which can be very
moving very important they could even be
called as called spiritual in some cases
we want to understand the riddle of the
universe we want to understand
consciousness if you want to understand
how the brain works these are all noble
goals some of them can be noble goals
anyway and they are a far cry from the
fundamental biological girl which is the
propagation of DNA but the machinery
that enables us to set up these
higher-level goals is originally
programmed into us by natural selection
of DNA the propagation of DNA but what
do you make of this unfortunate fact
that we are mortal do you ponder your
mortality does it make you sad the
I I ponder it it would it makes me sad
that I shall have to leave and not see
what's going to happen next if there's
something frightening about mortality
apart from sort of missing as I've said
something more deeply darkly frightening
it's the idea of eternity but eternity
is only frightening you feel their
eternity but before we were born
billions of years before we were born
and we were effectively dead before we
were born as I think was Mark Twain said
I was dead for billions of years before
I was born and never suffered the
smallest inconvenience that's how is
going to be afterward after we leave so
I think of it as really it eternity is a
frightening prospect and so the best way
to spend it is under a general
anesthetic which is what it'll be
beautifully put Richard there's a huge
honor to meet you to talk to you thank
you so much for your time thank you very
much
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Richard Dawkins and
thank you to our presenting sponsor cash
app please consider supporting the
podcast by downloading cash app and
using colex podcast if you enjoy this
podcast subscribe on youtube review with
five stars an apple podcast supported on
patreon or simply connect with me on
Twitter Alex Friedman and now let me
leave you with some words of wisdom from
Richard Dawkins we are going to die and
that makes us the lucky ones most people
are never going to die because they are
never going to be born the potential
people who could have been here in my
place but who will in fact never see the
light of day outnumber the sand grains
of Arabia certainly those unborn ghosts
include greater poets than Keats
scientists greater than Newton
we know this because the set of possible
people allowed by our DNA so massively
exceeds the set of actual people in the
teeth of these stupefying odds it is you
and I in our ordinariness there here we
privileged few who won the lottery of
births against all odds'
how dare we whine at our inevitable
return to that prior state from which
the vast majority have never stirred
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you